estamos en el problema número 11 nos
quedamos en este problema así que vamos
a responder lo dice
en la tabla siguiente se muestran
algunos valores de la función lineal
quédate para algunos valores
particulares de t cuál de los siguientes
sencillos define ag y bueno me da la
siguiente tabla así que voy a ponerle
aquí a tengo atm y por acá tengo
dt ok y tengo algunos valores para tema
de los valores para que de tema así que
vamos a ponerlos por acá tenemos unos
como por aquí y dice sí que vale menos
uno menos 101 y 27 que valores toma
bueno pues cuando te vale menos uno que
te toma un valor de 4 aquí tuvo un valor
de 2 aquí tuvo un valor de 0 le quitó un
valor de menos 2 perfecto ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que hablamos
de una función algete que es una función
lineal y como es una función lineal gt
se debe de ver que el dt tiene que tener
la forma m porte más b y si te das
cuenta en todos los incisos que tenemos
en este problema número 11 todos tienen
esta forma m porte más b
cuál de ellos es la opción correcta para
esto recordemos que significa b b es la
orden dada al origen o dicho otra manera
en donde interceptamos al eje de las 10
en este caso sería el eje o más bien
podremos verlo que cuando te vale 0 te
vale 0 qué valor toma 77 esto lo que
significa el valor debe hacer a t 0 y
ver qué valor tomas que de tema y si
nosotros nos damos cuenta aquí si te
vale 0 7 vale 2 es justo esto que tengo
aquí representado este este punto es el
que me va a servir o dicho otra manera
si sustituimos ante x 0 me quedaría g de
0 esto es igual a m por 0 + b pero esto
estos dos se van a cancelar porque m por
0 es 0 entonces más que dar kg de 0 que
por cierto sabemos que es 2 702 ok esto
lo tenemos por la tabla es va a ser
igual al valor de
al valor de 20 por lo tanto ya sabemos
un poco más acerca de esta función que
de tener la función que le teme tiene la
forma am emen porte más 2 porque ve vale
2 utilizando esta información que acaba
de obtener ahora si te das cuenta los
únicos dos incisos que tienen más dos en
el valor deben es el inciso d y el
inciso en el inciso d me dice que es
igual a menos temas dos a menos de más
dos mientras que el inciso
me dice que je t'aime es igual a menos
dos más dos
cuál será la respuesta correcta el 17 o
el inciso pues vamos a ver para eso
tenemos estos puntos así que no
compliquemos más la vida si te vale
menos 17 te debe de valer 4 vamos a ver
qué es lo que pasa de esta función
cuánto vale en esta función g de menos 1
bueno pues esto lo mismo que menos por
menos 1 + 2 y esto es lo mismo que 3 y
aquí me dicen que debe de valer 4 por lo
tanto antes puedo concluir que inciso d
no es mi respuesta correcta porque
cuando yo aplico g de menos uno llegó a
tres no llegó a cuatro vamos a ver si sí
es la respuesta correcta el psoe
cuánto vale que de menos uno en este
inciso e bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
menos 2 x menos 1
a las dos y esto va a ser igual a menos
2 x menos 1 estos 2 234 por lo tanto de
menos 1 en esta función en vale 4 y ya
está
esta es mi respuesta correcta porque
también funciona con este punto ahora
también si tú tienes un poco la duda
decide estos dos puntos cuando te vale 1
y cuando te vale dos funcionan podría
sustituir los en esta función que dt y
para saber que en efecto si funciona y
también te puedes dar cuenta que la
función que de tener orden no van a
funcionar ok
bueno ya tengo la respuesta del problema
número 11 vámonos al siguiente problema
problema número 12 problemas número 12 y
tengo una cuadrícula así que vamos a
hacer esta cuadrícula no sé si la
cuadrícula sea muy muy importante pero
vamos a ponerle aquí de todas maneras
por si no sirve entonces tengo
a grado más o menos así en un rectángulo
más o menos así
de una manera horizontal tengo 1 2 3 4 y
10 tengo 1 ok
después tengo 2 ok más o menos esto es
así después tengo 3
como por acá esta va a ser mínimo 3 y
por último tengo una cuarta por acá
tengo algo más o menos así y de manera
vertical tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 tengo 8
líneas verticales así que vamos a
ponerlas
una
al menos dos por qué
es más o menos así
algo más o menos así 44 algo más o menos
así 5 algo más o menos así
ok 6 algo más o menos así ok
7 algo más o menos así y por último 8
más o menos así bueno esta cuadrícula
poco rara pero es una cuadrícula nos va
a servir okay pensemos en qué es lo que
nos dice este problema aquí tengo el
grado aquí tengo el grado y tengo a
noveno grado noveno décimo grado onceavo
grado y décimo segundo grado ok y por
acá tengo los kilómetros
y además tengo a los kilómetros 1 2 3 4
78 perfecto y vamos a poner todos los
puntos que nos dan nos dan un montón de
puntos que son importantes ponerlos
tengo un punto por aquí tengo otro punto
por acá tengo otro por acá después tengo
otro por acá otro por acá ok
después tengo aquí en tres tengo otro
por acá y aquí en cuatro tengo otro por
acá ok en cinco solamente tengo 11 por
acá en 6 tengo estos 3 1 2 3 en 7 tengo
estos 2 este y este y por último en 8
tengo uno por acá y otro por acá
perfecto ya tengo esta cuadrícula y
vamos a ver qué me dice el problema ni
siquiera hemos leído el problema el
resultado de un estudio realizado a 16
estudiantes del bachillerato son son
están dados por la cuadrícula siguiente
esta muestra la distancia que viaja el
estudiante hasta la escuela en km es
justo esto la distancia que recordó el
estudiante de su casa de escuela y
redondeada al kilómetro más cercano ok
eso lo sabemos mientras que el eje que
muestra el grado que cursó el alumno en
este eje tenemos el grado que cursa el
alumno están en noveno grado décimo
grado onceavo grado o doceavo grado ok
utilizando los datos de la cuadrícula
cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones es
cierta veamos cuando son las
afirmaciones inciso a existe solamente
un estudiante que recorre dos kilómetros
a la escuela ok me dicen que me fijé en
dos kilómetros a la escuela así que sí
aquí tengo dos kilómetros quiero ver si
solamente hay un estudiante que cumpla
esto solamente un estudiante que cumpla
que recorre dos kilómetros y si te das
cuenta aquí tengo uno ok pero qué crees
aquí también tengo a otro
este este problema me decía que existe
solamente uno por lo tanto como existen
dos no existe solamente uno el inciso a
no es mi respuesta correcta ok no existe
solamente uno existen dos ahora
vamos a tomar otro color me gusta este
de aquí y dice inciso de la mitad de los
estudiantes recorren una distancia menor
a cuatro kilómetros para llegar a la
escuela una distancia menor a cuatro
kilómetros menor a cuatro kilómetros son
tres kilómetros dos kilómetros o un
kilómetro menor no es menor o igual es
menor por lo tanto vamos a fijarnos
solamente los que están antes de esta
recta que estoy dibujando justo aquí y
vamos a ver si son la mitad okay
contemos a me gusta este color en 12
345 estudiantes 5 estudiantes pero eran
16 estudiantes encuestados que le voy a
poner 16 esto
ya antes de estos 16 estudiantes a 5 que
no es la mitad
recuerden menos de 4 km por lo tanto el
inciso de tampoco es mi respuesta
correcta
ok pensemos en el inciso c el suizo se
me dice lo siguiente existen más
estudiantes de 12 grado que estudiantes
de onceavo grado que viajen 12
kilómetros o más a la escuela ok a ver
vamos con calma queremos fijarnos en los
estudiantes que viajen 6 kilómetros o
más a la escuela 6 kilómetros o más pues
son todos los que ustedes a partir de
esta recta de aquí a partir de esta
recta de aquí incluyendo esta recta
todos éstos vamos a fijarnos en todos
estos hilos que recuerdan 6 kilómetros o
más pueden ser 78 o los que sean por lo
tanto ya que tenemos esta recta nos
vamos a fijar en todos estos dos verdes
que tengo aquí
me dice existen más estudiantes de
doceavo grado que estudiantes del
onceavo grado que viajen 6 kilómetros o
más a la escuela de todos estos puntos
que están aquí cuántos son negocia
abogado bueno el onceavo grado tengo 12
y si nosotros pensamos en doceavo grado
en doceavo grado tengo 1
23 ahí esta es la respuesta tengo más
estudiantes de doceavo grado tengo tres
que estudiantes donde abogados que son
dos que viajan seis kilómetros o más a
la escuela ok esta es mi respuesta el
inciso c ya está aquí está en el 12 y
vamos a hacer el el siguiente problema
problema número 13 adiós esta cuadrícula
y vamos a hacer el problema número 14
recuerda que muchas veces el problema es
dibujar los problemas en lugar de
resolverlos el problema no estaba tan
difícil lo único que tenía que hacer era
tener mucho cuidado pero problema número
13 número 13
pero bueno es importante también dibujar
la cuadrícula para que entiendas de qué
estoy hablando y lo veas de una manera
más visual y además con más colores dice
cuántos enteros positivos de tres
dígitos
ok enteros positivos de tres dígitos
tengo 1
23 dígitos ok existen que tengan en el
dígito de centenas 13 aquí aquí están
las centenas
temas aquí están las decenas de más y
aquí están las unidades más
y la
y me piden que en el dígito que
corresponde a las centenas tengan un 3
aquí tengo un 3 forzosamente ok y además
que en el dígito que corresponde a las
unidades tengan un 4 es decir que aquí
forzosamente debo de tener un 4 en las
centenas de voy a tener un 3 en las
unidades debo tener un 4 y cuántos
números de tres dígitos existen que
tengan un 13 centenas y un 4 unidades
pues realmente esta pregunta creo que es
hasta capciosa está muy muy fácil lo
único que podemos variar es las decenas
lo único que podemos variar es el dígito
que está en las decenas y este dígito
puede tomar solamente los valores a 0 1
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y
nueve ya no puede tomar el 10 porque si
yo pongo aquí 10 me quedaría un número
no de tres dígitos sino de cuatro y si
yo pongo un número mayor que 9 10 11 12
lo que sea me va a quedar un número más
grande de tres dígitos por lo tanto
solamente tengo de opción 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 por ejemplo el 324 el 354 lo que
sea y como solamente tengo estas
posibilidades de aquí pues vamos a ver
cuántos números son a uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
westland la cantidad de dígitos que
tenemos es decir que existen solamente
diez posibles o sí
lees números números
que cumplan esta propiedad la primera
que las que en el dígito en el cual
están las centenas este 13 y el que el
dígito en el cual éste las unidades haya
un 4 entonces las respuestas el 10 y es
el inciso a perfecto creo que este
problema era muy fácil de hecho creo que
el problema de ese problema era pensar
que realmente este problema está tan
fácil que seguramente te hace dudar si
estamos bien o estamos mal pero es como
un problema caption fácilmente capciosa
ok problema número 13 se me ha acabado
el tiempo y nos vemos mejor en el
siguiente vídeo para atacar el problema
número 14 no te pierdas el siguiente
vídeo y hasta la próxima